yo what is up everybody this is prestige
mad Luigi and I'm gonna be showing you
guys how to play Gwent
in The Witcher 3 because I think a lot
of people might have a skip the tutorial
because they know the basic mechanics of
The Witcher or they didn't really see it
was clearly so I'm just gonna be running
through a game of Gwent which is if you
don't know it's a card game in The
Witcher 3 that you can play at a variety
of locations I'm gonna basically just be
running through a game and explaining
what I'm doing and what it all is so I'm
gonna go talk to this trader so I can
sell me a bunch of stuff as his main
purpose but is another purpose that this
specific the trader has is that he might
want to play Gwen so there are a lot of
people that can you can play Gwent with
whether it be from main quest givers or
Glenn masters or guys at taverns and so
you can just go wherever you want so now
you can see you can also bet so I'm
gonna bet I'm gonna bet 10 coins that I
win try and make some healthy cards so
this is a new game in The Witcher 3 and
so that's why a lot of people I think
even that play the previous games won't
understand what it is however it is
really basic so maybe this video might
not go out at anyone but regardless
we're gonna go through this so I'm gonna
be running through the basics in this
video and so I'm not gonna be exciting
to be a full in depth of everything so
I'm just gonna go with what I have right
here and I'm just gonna get right into
the game not enough cards um let's check
I don't know if cards total cards and
deck
total number of unit cards special cards
I'm gonna have enough cards there we go
we have enough cards all right let's try
at the game so you need at the I think
it showed at least 20-something cards
and because you get those cards that
your full deck is in the beginning it's
that and then you choose it takes ten
out of those random list so you don't
want to make your deck too big because
then you won't be able to choose the
cards that you really want
and at the beginning of each game you
can you can't are given the option to
redraw two of your cards so I'm going to
go over to those weaker guys and I'm
gonna redraw him and I'm gonna redraw
I'm gonna redraw this guy so now you see
I have these 10 cards and these are
these are it for the entire game except
if you have a special power like uh for
my faction though the northern realms I
get to draw one more card so I have this
to work with for three rounds plus one
extra my opponent who is also northern
realms will have the same type of deal
now the point of this game is to put
cards on the table and to end the round
with the more total points and if you
end the round with mode total points
then you win all the cards get discarded
from that round and you're left with the
next round with whatever you have left
so you don't want to use all your cards
in one round so then you lose the next
two rounds here's a three round game two
or three wins and they're also as there
are factions there are various leader
leaders and they give different leader
powers so we're gonna go right into it
um he plays that I'm actually gonna look
at this guy so he has a special ability
since you can see this is there how much
just attack damage and points they're
worth and there are three types of units
there are short range mid range and long
range the long ranges are seen two
ranges your mid count is your short
sword combat and then mid range is like
archery and stuff so place next to a
card with the same name to double the
strength of both cards oh that's why I
had two of them oh okay
well well and you can really only put
down one card per turns and then your
teammate your opponent not teammate what
does it get to go so I guess I'm just
gonna you don't want to go out big let's
let's start start small
see I place one card now he goes so he's
gonna hey I have a card we have just
have the same cindex I have a really
basic deck so I'm gonna let see what I
have and there are also weather cards
that can weaken a certain type of Union
there are three different with four to
four different weather cards I believe
one two week in each section of unit so
since the strength of all range to one
and I just have two of those so I'm
going to play what's he played so right
now I'm beating him because I have to
when he is one oh what's way what what
has happened place on your opponent's
battlefield and draw two cards
oh so that actually gave him two guards
I've never seen that card before alright
alright so he just got two extra cards
so he still has nine cars and I have
eight cards but I do have a good
advantage over him umm hmm what's what's
this ability choose one card from your
discard pile and play it instantly I
don't have any discard so her you want
to use second round
um so I play another short I'm gonna
diversify a little bit I really hope I
really can't
mmm he doesn't have any range I really
want plate is it I'm not gonna play any
range I'm just gonna play this guy I
don't see what he wants to do
what it what's another one of those
really he got another two cards he has
so many cards okay so we gotta think
about this and she has a good advantage
over us so let's see I don't think he
can play a seven drop in one round so
you know I'm gonna say so and you can
pass your turn whenever you think you
want to give up or you think the other
enemy can't beat you so I'm gonna gonna
pass and I'm gonna hope that his one
card isn't enough to be he has an eight
i well GG then GG I know there were even
eight in this are you kidding me are you
kidding me right now
whatever yep he pass oh he might he
might just be letting me win this round
um well I guess I have to play one guy
right let's see if he if he's just gonna
pass again oh so he passed so that means
I play one card I win
so yeah they just to give you the
victory so now you see I have seven
cards he has ten cards he's basically
just gonna be play as many cars as you
can try and get the biggest let's see
when we come on get something good gives
me good oh wait all I can choose I I can
choose which one I want awesome alright
alright let's see have a five I'm going
to I could play him four more cards
eight I have two fives I think I'm gonna
choose a five yeah I think I'll just
choose a father
so that's 1000 okay okay okay six a six
ballistic dang
I think I'll place my own tribe ashay
alright alright so this is kind of just
gonna be a mad dash playing cards
however he has I think he's gonna win
this cuz he has more cards than me and
yes it this is basically the game she
would he would need a pull six out next
turn to win I'd say it's kind of like my
best bet
what is this guy's ability place I don't
have another one of those GG let's see
let's see yeah I'm actually I'm gonna
I'm gonna try something I'm gonna place
that I'm gonna hope he doesn't play a
fog card alright alright so now my gap
is seven he does definitely have the
opportunity to pull out a seven but
since you already played an eight I
think it's gonna be pretty surprising if
he can also play a seven so now I'm just
conditions if I keep playing I'm just
gonna lose so I'm going to pass on my
turn and hope he can't beat me please
don't beat me please don't beat
yes all right boys oh no he can all
right JK that was I had a I had a false
I thought you can only play one card
even if your opponent passes you can
play as many cards as you want okay so
and yeah I just I just lost
I just lost my money all right well that
is the those are the basics of the game
went and you can go around the world and
be better players and look in higher up
shops to get better cards and once you
get all those better cards then you can
build a better deck and so those are
basically everything I want to show you
guys for Gwent hope you guys have
enjoyed I'm gonna be posting a lot more
Witcher content in the coming days and I
as weeks so keep looking around my
channel if you like witcher like the
witcher 3 and you
this video was pretty swag so that's
about it I'm gonna see you guys later
peace up